cette saison chez lanvin chez cerruti
chez dior
c'est le règne du manteau long et du
costume trois pièces contraignant faire
les eaux et d'écoles l'immaculée qui
enserre le coup le dandysme c'est aussi
milord l'arsouille et les gentlemen
boxeur c'est moi la collection de jean
paul gaultier
je fais de la mort de la voix de
couronnes je crois que jusqu'à présent
enfin les a pas de réflexion qu'elle
avait pas vraiment le mode voilà c'était
toujours le costume homme attend ce
faire est-ce qui va être avec un col un
petit peu plus petits aux plus grands
avec les chemises rouges avec une
cravate jaune posséder ce genre de
questions là bas maintenant je propose
des vêtements qu'on peut mélanger porter
une passion différence mais pas assez
classique
les volumes sont bien étudiés mais elle
est quelquefois même des matières aussi
blessé j'ai aussi il ya des pressions
efforts des différents qui n'ont pas les
choses peuvent paraître agressive
ses inspirations mad max pour le soir
ambiance totalement discret y gens pas
de l'uci fait son cirque et c'est un
vrai qu'il y fera ce qu'il sait nous
amuser enfin quand la mode des grands
dinho l'aise que c'est bien sûr jean
paul gaultier qui est derrière c'est le
show pour le show pour le reste cela en
est sera froid plus d'un mais des goûts
et des couleurs on ne discute pas ce qui
est certain c'est que ce n'est pas pour
rien que jean paul gaultier organise ses
défilés au cirque d'hiver